[Music]
we wanted there to be tons of mutants
there was this huge well of mutant
characters that were kind of under
utilized really there are other mutants
like us
and we met with Ice Cube and we said
okay the character's name is Superfly
and he looks like this ice cube laughed
and smiled and we're like I think he's
in it
it's the cool super villain I'm a cool
super villain I decided to kill all the
humans and let the mutants rule the
Earth
that's a take the Ninja Turtles kind of
get this idea that if they stop super
fight and those mutants maybe that'll be
a thing that proves to people that
they're good and that they should be
accepted it was pretty cool to see
Superfly with his crew of mutants I'm so
sorry I didn't introduce my peace why
steady Bebop hey what you looking at bro
what you looking at Mondo Gekko peoples
they got to give Wing nuts
[Music]
don't patronize me leather head oh I get
right fellas this idea of kind of like
bringing it to this like monster movie
type place was really fun and exciting
it's called mutant Mayhem
we have a very important mission for
tonight we must use stealth and cunning
to infiltrate the human world and
retrieve
go courage
okay Batman I'm just trying to Hype you
guys up let's go from Seth Rogen comes a
movie that crushes for absolutely every
age
amazing insane all right tell me more
it's effortlessly cool and Visually
stunning it's the most fun you'll have
at the movies this year
[Music]
that seems very dangerous see danger for
breakfast actually I eat pizza with bits
of waffles on it
with the funniest casts ever assembled
enough oh man you can't stop us
we're the only ones who can do this
I'm awesome we're brothers we fight
together we're just getting started
[Music]
she sounded like a leader I do oh I do
oh I sound like such a leader and you
ruined it
Ninja Turtles
remember don't let any human see you
theaters August 2nd get your tickets now
[Music]